BRAID AN STARTS AGAINST AUSTIN
MATTHEWS AND THAT'S GOING TO BE
BOGOSI GOING BACK ALL
THAT WAY WITH TH.
>> Keith: THE LEAFS ACTUALLY
WITH WIN.
TORONTO NOW REORGANIZEINIZES A .
CRIS CROSSIN
MATTHEWST SELL IT AS
BEST YOU CAN, RIGHT, JONESY?NO,F
>> Keith: WELL, WHAT A RESPONSE?
ALL THE BODIES STACKED UAND TO .
MOVED ALONG, TWO ON ONE.
TAL, KILLORN THE OUTSIDE. TO
AVOID SPEZZA GETS IT I I
JOHN TARVARIS.
7.8 SECONDS LEFT.
THE LINE.
>> Colby: BIG FACE-OFF WIN,
KUCHEROV POWER PLAY GOAL.
POINT TOWARDS SOMETHING DOWN
HERE IN THE CORNER.
EVERYONE WAS ON THEIR FEET IN
THT GOES TO WORK.
HERE COMES MUZZIN.
TARV TORONTO.
>> John: SATURDAY NIGHT IF
NEEDED.
TORONTO, THE
CAPTAIN GOT ON THE SCORE SHEET
WISH TO SO FAR.
TARVARIS WITH TWO IN FRONTD
LEFT IN BACK OF THE GOALHE NET